from Peter Kings Monday football morning
in America colum his thoughts on how the
playoffs will shake out he likes the
Steelers to miss out the ravens to win
the division and be the four seed he
likes the Chiefs to be the number one
seed which means they'll beat the
Raiders or some other combination of
events and the cult says we've been
talking about throughout the program
Peter likes them to beat the Titans so
he's got Chiefs one Patriots two Texans
three ravens four Chargers five Colt six
in the NFC much of it's already been
decided Saints already number one
Cowboys already number four Peter likes
the Rams at two bears at three Seattle
to hold and the number five spot and the
Vikings by virtue of either a victory
over the Bears or a Eagles loss the
Vikings the number sixteen I assume you
you think the Vikings are gonna win the
game
I assume that's how you have them at
number six yeah I do Mike but that
obviously was the toughest call for me
it was even tougher than Colts Titans
just because I think the Bears are
really gonna play hard and try to win
this game and and if that happens her
cousin's is gonna have to come through
Mike
there is no single player in the NFL
this weekend week 17 who's got more
pressure on him than Kirk Cousins he's
got to show that he's the long-term
quarterback not just the short-termer
again for the Minnesota Vikings not
gonna be there for just three years he
he has to start showing that he can win
games of great magnitude that he can
beat the Chicago Bears to get the
Vikings into the playoffs that he can
win a playoff game that's what they paid
for and that is going to be vital for
Kirk Cousins this weekend and and you
know when you look at the Vikings and
the season they've had the games they've
played the schedule they faced the night
games the big high-profile games I'm not
surprised
they're eight six and one with one game
left to play I think the Vikings did a
bad job of tempering expectations
locally so many Vikings fans just
believed hey all right
upgrade from Case Keenum to Kirk Cousins
upgrade from the final four to the
Boult it's that simple and clearly it's
not when you have a tougher schedule
when you have a new offensive
coordinator who ultimately is fired
during the season and you know the
Vikings should be happy they're even
still alive at this point given the
adversity they faced this year but I
agree with you Peter Kirk Cousins under
the most pressure of anyone he arguably
has the most to lose because it's more
than just losing that playoff spot it's
losing that luster it's losing that
sense that the Vikings did the right
thing by committing 84 million dollars
to him other than that whether it's a
player whether it's a coach whether it's
a team who do you think has the most to
lose going into this weekend I think
there's two I'd focus on two teams and
two teams overall number one the Rams I
think that if if somehow someway the
49ers went into LA and beat them and
force them you know if the Bears could
win that game force them to play
wildcard weekend that would be an
incredible comedown from a team that
five weeks ago we thought could very
well be the best team in football that's
number one and I having number two the
Houston Texans Houston has played at
times like you know a top five team in
football and at times they played like
the 15th best team in football you know
especially you know even less than that
at the beginning of the year but I think
the Houston Texans this this is a more
than just a little speed bump game the
Jacksonville Jaguars in my opinion and
especially Blake bortles have got an
awful lot to play for on Sunday Doug
Marrone possibly his job Blake bortles
his future and and this defense that is
a tough tough defense if they come to
play and we're only gonna know that
after a couple of series on Sunday but
if the Jaguars come to play that is not
a walkover game for the Houston Texans
but it is a game that the Houston Texans
must win I remember starting the 2017
season the Texans had the Jaguars coming
to town to her
canid happened it was a galvanizing
force locally the Jaguars were coming to
town the Jaguars are never any good the
Texans had playoff aspirations I thought
it was going to be a blowout for the
Texans the Jaguars won the game 29 to 7
so you know these divisional round games
when you get into week 17 when you're
playing another team from your division
even if that team's out of it
the fact that they don't like you that
brings another element to these games
the Jaguars yeah they don't have
anything to play for but they can screw
up things for the tech for the Texans so
it's worth it so I agree with you the
Texans could put themselves in a very
bad spot because if they lose that game
they are not winning the AFC South
they'll be on the road in the postseason
another team in the AFC that has plenty
to lose Kansas City Chiefs
Peter I mean they got that number one
seed in grasp all they have to do is
beat the Raiders if they can't beat the
Raiders at home in a game that will
deliver home-field advantage throughout
the playoffs I don't have any faith in
the Chiefs to go on the road and win I
don't have any faith in the Chiefs to do
anything as a team even though they have
the best player in football right now in
Patrick mahomes you know this is really
an ancillary note to this mic but I
think one of the most important players
for the Chiefs down the stretch of this
season is going to be a guy a month ago
that nobody ever heard of Damien
Williams this is a guy who now has to
assume the role a very very valuable
role of the key running back in this
offense he's got to be what Kareem hunt
was and so far he's shown some signs
that he could be that guy now he's not
as good he's not as as shaky you know
with his hips as Kareem hunt is but in
my opinion the Chiefs did a really
really smart thing this year this week
in signing Damian Williams for the next
two years because they're probably
probably gonna enter this offseason
looking for a running back but knowing
that they've got Damian Williams who's
good enough as insurance for them for
the future and right now he's a vital
part of this team coming into the
postseason and they definitely need that
Peter because without Sammy
Watkins and this is a point that Chris
Sims makes all the time they're paying
Sammy Watkins Odell Beckham jr. money
he hasn't been available the past
several weeks the offense is different
when he's not on the field because then
they can put more attention on Tyreke
kill you need both of those guys on the
field to make that offense go to make it
as unstoppable as it was earlier this
year and to make up for a defense that
isn't good enough to allow the Chiefs to
take advantage of great performances
from Patrick mahomes we've seen four
prime-time losses this year from the
Kansas City Chiefs and in every game
Patrick mahomes played well but it's the
defense that ultimately lets them down
whether it's the Patriots game the Rams
the chargers most recently the Seahawks
it's not on the homes
it's on the defense so whether it's
Damian Williams stepping up whether it's
getting Sammy Watkins back they need
some help or they're gonna have a rough
time in the playoffs and if they can't
beat the Raiders on Sunday it's going to
be another quick exit for an Andy Reid
team from the postseason so we've
identified the Rams the Texans the
Chiefs the Vikings as teams with plenty
to lose I still think the bay and this
is this gets back to your point that the
Bears are going to play hard
look that they've got they've got
something to lose here because they've
got plenty to gain if they get lucky and
the 49ers beat the Rams the Bears
getting a bye week and forcing the Rams
to come to Soldier Field
that would be huge and I think that that
gives the Bears every reason to come out
and do everything they can to knock out
the Vikings even though even though the
risk is if you if you beat the Vikings
and the Rams win you probably have the
Eagles coming to town Peter which
becomes which means you become the next
notch in the nick foles belt as he
continues this magical run and we talked
about this earlier in the program if
you're the Bears I think you'd rather
have the Vikings come to town next week
than the Eagles and the one other thing
you mentioned you're assuming that if
somehow the Rams are the third seed
you're assuming that the Rams are gonna
beat either the Eagles or the Vikings in
that first game Mike I'm not assuming
that at all at all and you know because
in my opinion of all the teams that
are going to have home games in the
playoffs this year you know if forum
holds all those teams to me the Rams
have the the the the least home-field
advantage of all of them it's it's been
they've been ok at home because they've
been a good team but they have not been
able to use that home field to get the
kind of home-field edge I was at the
Packers Rams game and and with the
exception of the of the time on gummer
II stupid play at the end they probably
lose that game and I would bet that
there's 40,000 Packer fans in the crowd
that day now again that's not gonna
happen in the playoffs
but you know what if the Eagles get in I
bet 25,000 Evils fans finding their way
to the Coliseum for that game if it's if
that's where they're playing and so to
me I just III don't assume that the Rams
win anything now because I quite frankly
do not know who the Rams are at this
moment several of those games this year
for the Bram's at home felt more like
Super Bowls than home games for one team
the Vikings had a large contingent of
fans there week for Thursday night games
so I agree with you and given that they
lost last year at home to the Falcons in
the wild-card round the Rams are gonna
quickly become the bengals if they can't
figure out how to hold serve at home
whether it's in the last year's at the
Coliseum or the new stadium that's going
to soon be opening both the Rams and the
Chargers need to get a real home-field
advantage or they are going to have
trouble when they do host playoff game
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports